[Music]
and didn't happen news submitted by
master of disaster a viral Keanu Reaves
interview is now being reported as fake
oh Jesus are we there you know wait deep
fix isn't now an interview form I like
that the nicest person no he seems like
you like everyone says all the time good
energy I would like to have that
reputation Fendley but I don't put in
the work for that and I go the opposite
route yeah so recently there were a lot
of media outlets picking up this article
that claims that he said that he's just
a lonely guy but it turns out that Keanu
Reeves is camp there saying that that
interview never happened and that quote
that they used was from 2003 who isn't
yeah who isn't lonely every once in a
while though
how do people keep track of their
interviews to find that oh yeah I said
that in 2003 I can barely know people
are [ __ ] lazy they don't check their
work that's crazy and so this is the
interview he still looks like Last
Samurai oh why was I thinking a video I
thought so too I thought it was like an
interview interview like a face-to-face
no it was written like a questionnaire
kind of thing
so it says the question is obviously the
matrix means a lot to you how much like
neo are you and then counter Reese
responds he's a better man in me but I
try to live up to his values another
question which of his qualities do you
particularly admire he answers he was a
beautiful man to play I thought his love
fraternity was so pure I really
identified with it also I loved his
search for answers he was strong
positive moral and ethical man doing the
best he can question what does love mean
to you answer you mean romantic love you
know I'm the lonely guy I don't have
anyone in my life but if it does occur I
would respect and love the other person
hopefully it'll happen for me and in
question you describe yourself as a
lonely guy what are you are you content
with that answer I don't concern myself
with that much I'm an actor so in terms
of what you're asking about I have no
answer so how was it taken out of
context why was it brought up yeah why
is it a big deal cuz we posted in 2019
like he just said it exactly so I think
unethical journalism [ __ ] yeah but even
if it is let's say he was lonely in 2090
what's so wrong being you okay because
they're pitching it as hey new interview
with Keanu Reeves but it's someone
else's work Chanel see it comes off as
like he's troubled and there's something
wrong going on in his life when there's
no controversy really they're just
trying to stir up [ __ ] leave the man
alone dude do you have a picture of
canneries and it says I'm lonely that's
that that's what the craze in the image
right that he's like in depression or
something and then it's quick baby I
don't want any of those images go okay
cool I just I feel like everyone's
lonely every once in a while it's like
him going like a picture of calories it
goes I'm hungry I'm like probably are
every once in a while but people are
actively searching for drama online and
they're like oh [ __ ] he's lonely what's
going on in his life that's that's
making him filled out didn't he have a
really sad life like some terrible [ __ ]
his happy news life right I think with
his parents I think that's why he tries
to do so much good and his pops left um
yeah I think it pops left him at like a
really young age or something all right
someone died his old mother his
girlfriend or something I don't know I
just know he collects motorcycles the
journalist who reported this
his name is Phillip Burke and he was a
former Hollywood Foreign Press
Association president Wow no first of
the queen of the Andals so he's saying
that yeah so that one quote about him
like the matrix thought like yeah it was
from 2003 but it's still he still said
it we still we actually have dear this
is what this one because now they defend
why can't they just do retractions you
know we [ __ ] up right especially we're
just lazy writing we wanted it this is
such a common practice now because all
the press people now are [ __ ]
Millennials
yeah and so they're all like oh I'm not
taking responsibility for it and they
already got the clicks they wanted right
yeah so then it's also you get sued yeah
can't undo those clips so he was also
saying like we do we have notes proving
that
interview did take place that's not why
they're under fire I'm April 2019 oh
yeah it's because piano Reeves
spokespeople are saying that that that
interview didn't even happen
oh I said the journalist is saying well
yeah we do we can confirm that an
interview happen at the Four Seasons in
LA in April 2019 and like they have
provided transcribed quotes of the
meeting then he said he's lonely again
um no no so like that was the rest of
the interview but that adds like they're
saying ask for the lonely guy statements
mr. Berk clarified that the quote came
from a previous interview that he had
with Keanu Reeves and he has provided us
with crap transcribed notes so that's
just trying to argue the fact that that
was that that's a combination of that
interview with the same journalist yeah
sixteen years apart from that one
particular quote [ __ ] stretch just
take the L bro so there's more to this
brick guy so he was last year Brendan
Fraser Freight freezer
Fraser yeah yeah anyway that guy he told
GQ that Burke had sexually assaulted him
at a 2003 luncheon in Beverly Hills and
how do you do that isn't beneficial huge
I feel like when he walked up and
grabbed his ass something happen I Terry
Crews - you can't do anything back if
they have some power over you yeah I
like in that high place at a luncheon so
they were just eating like at earth
caffeine he got it so no no he told him
over lunch like know how you were at a
luncheon in Beverly Hills I just
pictured Urth Caffe like half soup half
sandwich yep don't want those combos or
salad if you're watching the way here
that the groping so Burke told GQ that
the alleged groping incident was a total
fabrication but that he did acknowledge
that he sent Brendan in letter of
apology that admitted no wrongdoing and
then I'm sorry if we're not doing
anything wrong
yes that same thing the Hollywood
Foreign Press Association they did an
investigation into the incident and
after Frazier's interview and then they
said that they were previously
see unaware of the accusation but that
the organization ultimately determined
that the groping was intended as a joke
and the Frazer was like I don't get the
joke but yeah so this guy is like he's
been in [ __ ] and then and the Hollywood
Foreign Press constantly covers for him
yeah way is even earn elasaur the owner
of the Prague so here the former
president of this the Hollywood Foreign
Press Association uh-huh and he's also
the journalist who wrote about Keanu oh
okay well he's a scumbag
yeah so because instead of going like
this is what he looks like he's like
defending and he's like yeah the
interview happened he looks like he
gives hand jobs at Urth Caffe yeah he
does while you're eating a sandwich [ __ ]
all the sack on his forehead don't just
give up after that just shave it off man
like don't [ __ ] bother by the time
it's like now you can put like six
houses that's Pleasant rainbow but yes
it makes the rest of the of the
Hollywood Foreign Press look terrible so
speaking about them they also added in
this article that another former
Hollywood Foreign Press Association
presidents came under fire in October
2018 after it was revealed that this in
Egypt airs in-flight magazine published
a phony interview with Drew Barrymore
and so yeah they're just all dandy all
suck yeah all right that's why I love
the Internet
accountability [ __ ] yeah but then that
like the Hollywood Foreign Press
they keep standing by their lives their
lives yeah because you're saying they
have to they don't have to they could
just be like yo this is [ __ ] up we
apologize and retract
nobody does that [ __ ] anymore [ __ ]
crazy they just delete tweets now yes
because people get penalized for
admitting to guilt
it makes people other people afraid to
feeling like they you know that that
they did something wrong or a meeting to
wrong right yeah yeah don't or like if
you have a good
ecology and you you just don't have any
excuses and you were just saying sorry
then then they'll always bring it back
just take the [ __ ] L man it makes you
all look better if you take the LT
responsibility that's a like a boo [ __ ]
but I mean the old guard is dying the
old guard is dying anyway all these
people are [ __ ] gonna keep droppin
that's what I think is really going on
and I think the old guards dying so hard
like all the print papers and stuff
everything's so [ __ ] for them yeah
desperate to hold on to the reputations
so they will defend their shittiness
even like in individual cases and it
seems like it's happening everywhere
from politics to all sorts of industries
and all that [ __ ] I watch this you know
those paparazzi that bother celebrities
all time to get that one shot I wonder
how much they get paid for a good [ __ ]
time depending on who it is really if it
took of if it's like Beyonce yeah like
if it if they're her and jay-z argh
fighting right that's the story and then
they also happened to see them kissing
oh and a paparazzi gets out you could
tell for several million dollars no what
do you think there's [ __ ] running down
Lady Diana yeah you're going 110 after
Lady Diana cuz they do you think it's
kind of like gone down now that everyone
has a camera on their hands Oh Mike I
don't know people just taking photos of
celebrities posting them online for free
maybe but I mean a paparazzi photo
versus a phone photo completely
different cuz they have that [ __ ]
telescopic [ __ ] leg I think it
depends if it's breaking news right
that's crazy dude I love it it's not
like you're just catching a celebrity
walking down the street and it's like
look at them in sweats those those are
probably like 50 grand or whatever 50
grand
I'm just [ __ ] I've actually met I've
actually met a paparazzi and it's it's
in the it's in that zone those regular
pictures it is a five bigger that's why
is he like with those breaking news
things like like Princess Diana or
anything that's like jay-z fighting with
salon drew was it smart yes salon yeah
yeah and then I guess things like that
those are the ones that are lots of
money due to any on the end the other in
the spectrum it's like you always see
the picture it's like we got Vinny from
Jersey Shore walking out of it
he [ __ ] calls
hey please take a picture of me coming
out of the gym okay Teemo call them my
grade there's Benny over here spot and
they're like I guess there's nothing
else going and some of that they even
pay those guys
yeah the medium to post like a Daily
Mirror article about that doesn't the
equivalent paying for fake Instagram
followers at work stolen that thing is
too like paparazzi shots they own those
so if the celebrity tries to repos
that's been a few times and they're
crazy I just don't get to as long as
business business I'm good at finding
people
it's great because it's a picture of you
and then you get sued for posting a
picture of yourself
oh that's great that's America
[Music]